- Like, look at that, hey, oh my God.
- I'm tackling a little
bit of a phobia today.
- I've never worn heels before.
- I like heels on women.
- Oh, they're sexy.
- I feel like there's a
pressure on gay people that
they're supposed to be able
to wear them without fail.
- I'm excited to strut.
- I mean I'm sure I'll look nice and sexy.
- Make it happen.
These are terrify--, these are weapons.
- This is like a toothpick.
This thing is for sure gonna break.
Alright, I'm just gonna go for it.
- Ah, it's giving me anxiety.
- Oh, God, it's already bad.
- Already feeling sexier.
- One, two, three,
Ooooh, (bleep) me!
- This is the worst.
- I don't like this, oh my God.
- I can't stand straight,
I can't, I can't stand.
- Because I'm afraid that I'll fall.
- Whoa! Okay.
- Ha, ha, ha, ha!
- Whew! Here we go.
- Oh (bleep).
- This is pain city over here.
- It's like walking for the first time.
- Jeez, I'm like pushing 6'9" right now.
- I feel sexy, hold up, let
me strut, let me get this.
- I'm just figuring out that if you like
swing your hips with it, you get more like
distribution of weight.
- Props to models that can
walk in a straight line
without looking like a horse.
- I kinda wanna get good at it, you know.
- Oh, I've got the hang of it.
- I like the sound that it makes.
- Like a workout.
- My muscle in my leg is
literally going like this.
- They should have these at the gym.
Just some bros, like put on
some heels and just walk.
And then that's like ooh, one set.
- I'm sweating 'cause I'm working so hard.
- Like my calves like, look at that.
- This is harder than
football practice, for sure.
- I feel a little bit
like a rock star though.
- It kinda feels like
you're hiking or something
and you step on a log by accident.
But the log is always in your shoe.
- My feet are in mousetraps right now.
- I forgot that women have to
wear these for a whole day.
- By the end of the day, I
would want to cut off my feet.
I understand why every woman
I've ever met wants a foot rub.
- Can you imagine doing this drunk?
- I thought I'd be better
at this than I was.
Work!
- Oh, it's kinda almost like
worth it to just put them on
just so you can take them off later.
Because it's gonna feel amazing.
- It was worse than I expected.
- I didn't think it was that hard.
Actually, I thought it
was gonna be harder.
- I find back, pssht,
chicks do this all the time.
- I'm like at a loss for words.
- I already feel like my calves
are getting strengthened.
- Next time I'm dancing with a chick
I'm just gonna be like, "Are you okay?"
- I would never ask you to do this for me.
- This has changed my
view on heels forever.
I'm never, like if I see a heel in a store
I'm walking the other way.
- To all fabulous women
and drag queens out there,
I salute you.
- Wait, this is (bleep) up, hold on.